The Spectator magazine combines incisive
political commentary with books and arts
reviews of unrivaled authority stock up
on your summer reading with a 12 week
subscription in print and online for
just pile pounds plus we'll send you a
copy of Spectator columnist Lionel
Shrivers new book the motion of the body
through space absolutely free go to
Spectator Kudo UK forward slash Lionel
hello and welcome to OD a weeks this
week Fraser Nelson makes the case for
why we should be giving citizenship to
the Hong Kong Chinese we also hear from
Douglas Murray who asks why lockdown
seems to be exempt for black lives
matter protests and finally Tonya Gould
our restaurant critic turns her hand at
monstermunch
first up phrasing arson when the fates
of Hong Kong was last seriously
considered by a British prime minister
the world looks very different it was
argued naively but not much would change
when the colony was handed back to China
in 1997 there was a deal that had been
struck Beijing would run only the
defense and the customs control and
otherwise Hong Kong would be
self-governing now it was always
unlikely that China would honor his
promise but the pretense at the time was
pretty useful to a Tory party that was -
it's chained terrified of the
alternative of admitting that Britain
had a moral duty to his subjects and to
let them stay British which meant
allowing them to settle in the UK if
they wished the deal with China is now
in tatters Beijing has been gnawing away
at Hong Kong's liberties for years and
is now engaged in an all-out assault the
street protests which had been going on
for almost a year ended with a covert
lockdown but China has used the
interregnum to come back with his
biggest crackdown yet last month said
the Hong Kong will become subject to
Beijing's laws on subversion visa laws
currently used to jail Tibetan and ergo
dissenters other crackdowns and free
speech are also on the way so in other
words we've seen an end to the one
country two systems' treaty agreed in
the handover an end to Britain's deal
with China and an end to our ability to
dodge the question what is Boris Johnson
going to do now but the answer so far is
actually quite a lot the Prime Minister
has offered a full-throated defense of
the Hong Kong Chinese with the kind of
passion that would have been unthinkable
in the coalition years back then George
Osborne had a very different policy on
China
he wanted to secure a bigger slice of
his economic pie as possible getting as
many contracts and as much cash back to
Britain as he could get away with and as
he knew there are unwritten rules for a
country which and as he knew there are
unwritten rules for countries who play
this game never receive a Dalit llama as
a guest never raised the subject of
human rights during foreign visits the
Chinese press actually praised Teresa
May for perfecting this peculiar art
never challenged you Jinping's ambition
to control China's periphery and most of
all no support or succor should ever be
given to Taiwan Tibet or especially the
young protester is waving the British
flag in the streets of Hong Kong if any
of his rules are broken then so are
relations with Beijing it is
extraordinary just how fast Boris
Johnson is dumping David Cameron's
policy he's emerged from the covert
crisis shaken by the extent of Britain's
reliance on China and he's ready to
reset relations even if that means a far
harder stance the foreign secretary
Dominic Raab has declared China to be in
breach of international law with his
latest crackdown and he's talking about
Britain's historical responsibilities to
the people of Hong Kong and he's
actually given a meaty policy to the end
of this he's letting them come here on a
12-month visa rather than a standard six
months this he describes as a pathway to
citizenship it's an offer that applies
to almost three million people who
currently qualify for British national
brackets overseas status this is a kind
of passport it's a consolation prize
given to the Hong Kong Chinese which
entitles holders to virtually nothing it
will now mean a bit more the right to
stay here for a year with the
possibility of permanent citizenship
dangled tantalizingly but I'm afraid to
say it still studded with doubt what
would actually happen at the end of 12
months what does a pathway to
citizenship mean not very many of the
high skilled migrants Britain seeks are
likely to move from one country to
another on such a relatively flimsy
promise
Britten's opportunity is to go the
hallway and offer full citizenship that
is what we should have done in the first
place and that case can be made and you
weaken starts with immortal arguments
made by this magazine three decades ago
Hong Kong was only ever Britain's under
a 99 year lease the land itself had to
revert but the people they are never to
have been parceled up with him they
ought never to be handed over to anybody
at the time respecting to argue the
sino-british agreement of 1984 afforded
nobody any real protection we're giving
him nothing in which they can have
confidence the editorial said Hong Kong
is a colony which means that Britain has
an absolute responsibility to his people
particularly as unlike another colonies
those people have not actually asked for
independence full citizenship we argued
was the only decent offer to make now
the pretends that Hong Kong's
independence would be respected by the
agreement of 20 47 was impossible to
keep up even when Boris Johnson was
foreign secretary when he was out there
commemorating the 20th anniversary of
handover he ascribed the territory's
success to a high degree of autonomy as
enshrined in the sino-british joint
declaration he was the only one
attaching any importance to that Beijing
rubbished it with a foreign ministry
spokesman dismissing this treaty as
quote a historical document which no
longer has any practical significance
Beijing has since been as good as its
broken word six years ago pro-democracy
protesters were using umbrellas to
defend themselves against the tear gas
of the police the protest failed but the
umbrellas became a symbol of the
movement Beijing has been sending over
meanwhile increasingly authoritarian
legislation for the Hong Kong
authorities to approve there was the
extradition law this time last year
which brought 12,000 protesters out onto
the streets last month they proposed to
make booing the Chinese national anthem
producible by five years imprisonment
this is a bit of a problem for the Hong
Kong football fans who've grown quite
fond of booing
that anthem now they can get scented the
Gulag if they do so all of this bodes
pretty ill for the future its observed
now to think that the Tories were so
terrified of granting free movement to
just three million people in Hong Kong
given that hundreds of millions of youth
citizens have had the same right Britain
has since proven itself to be the
world's most successful melting pot
integrating five million migrants over
the past decade with none of the
far-right political backlash seen on the
continent it's pretty hard to argue that
there'd be any problem in settling the
Hong Kong Chinese the best educators and
the most highly skilled and productive
immigrants that any country could ask
for the breads of debate exposed several
misunderstandings anyway about the
concern of immigration it's not that
people feel Britain is fool this was a
claim made even in 1984 when our Islands
accommodated 10 million fewer people
than they do now the concern is about
the ability to control immigration and
brigs it has brought that control you
can see in the opinion polls as a result
the concern about immigration since
Briggs it has plunged Britain is one of
the most welcoming countries in the
world and welcoming Hong Kong Chinese
who were until recently fellow subjects
of the crown would not be something that
would do cries anything like public
discontent at a time anyway when
countries are competing for the
high-skilled people Britain's moral duty
and its economic self-interest have
become aligned as one Tory MP puts it
the biggest problem is how many the Hong
Kong Chinese we can actually win over
here but Britain on this front really is
at a disadvantage the Foreign Office has
calculated that those leaving Hong Kong
are more likely to go to countries with
a large diaspora Canada and Australia
for example squirrel pretty strongly on
this front having acted to taking tens
of thousands at the time of the handover
when Britain did not our behavior then
was pretty bad and it will have led to a
loss of confidence in Britain that's
something we're going to have to make up
for now
so perhaps even the offer a fool
citizenship will not be enough we should
be waiting paperwork fees to underline
the fact that this time we really are
serious and there's plenty of president
for us making this offer in the 1960s
Uganda's agents were facing persecution
from Idi Amin who was saying that he'd
been told in a dream to expel them Ted
Heath's government then arranged
airlifts and people were then arriving
in their thousands and what David
Cameron did later described as one of
the most successful group of migrations
anywhere in the history of the world
among those newcomers were Susheela
and and Janet Patel whose daughter Priti
Patel is now our Home Secretary the
parallels between the Hong Kong Chinese
and those of other situations are not
lost on her nor on Dominic Raab who's
Jewish father came to Britain from
Czechoslovakia to escape the Nazis in
the pre-war years both of them will be
working since September to set up a fast
stream solution for Hong Kong and the
way they both see it this is not just
about the fate of a few million people
in Hong Kong this is about Britain's
rule in the world one cabinet member put
it this way look around the cabinet
table there was Dominic Raab Priti Patel
Rishi cynic all children of immigrants
who just see this whole question a
different way that we're looking here at
a British tradition but needs to be
lived up to and the Prime Minister said
that said the cabinet member has been
absolutely rock-solid on this he's been
the one leading it so the funny thing is
that the pressure from Tory backbenchers
this time isn't to hoist up the
drawbridge like it was Norman Tebbit day
the pressure is for government to stand
behind Hong Kong and not given to
Beijing to emigrate from Hong Kong
requires what they call a certificate of
no criminal conviction demand for these
certificates are now running at a
hundred a day a rise at 50 percent over
last year that's a sign that there might
be an exodus pretty soon Portugal's
former Europe minister Bruno Mathias
has argued in a piece for the spectators
website the Britain can now make itself
a you
Rajon capital were welcoming the best
and the brightest from Hong Kong one
option he said is to use brexit powers
to create Hong Kong style low regulation
charter cities in Britain
perhaps for north of England and
encourage the same culture of
entrepreneurship here visi said conserve
our two systems one country system in
Britain just as you do in Hong Kong and
you can merge it with number tens
leveling up agenda the opportunities for
the human capital here are absolutely
huge but to make most of them Britain
will have to act and act fast you can
see why ministers are reluctant to offer
a full citizenship a bill would take
time to pass Parliament and risk legal
challenge from those who say that other
migrant groups deserve the same
treatment so the ministers are arguing
that right now what they're doing this
plan for 12-month visas along with the
offer to a path citizenship is a
backdoor means of achieving the same
result
so why ministers ask will we take the
harder route of offering full
citizenship if they all risk a backlash
in Parliament and perhaps in the wider
country I'm afraid to say it was a
simple answer to that question Britain
has lost credibility we let Hong Kong
down badly last time that's why we need
to make firm assurances this time some
argue but an exodus from Hong Kong would
actually suit Beijing removing the
pro-democracy troublemakers perhaps so
but we can no longer regard them as
pawns to be deployed on a diplomatic
chess board the choice surely should be
theirs and anyway the past 23 years have
shown that Hong Kong is not making China
more democratic instead China's making
Hong Kong more autocratic contrary to
Britain's promises at the time that's
precisely why the offer of full
citizenship should be made now you can
certainly say that Boris Johnson's up
for a fight he's urged China to back
down and he said that Britain is
standing ready to act if Beijing pursues
its crackdown but this global Britain
agenda that was his
it was never really given life when his
foreign secretary even presenting the
option of full British citizenship would
empower those who wish to stay just by
letting Beijing know but if they do push
things too far then people will flee
Hong Kong just as surely as so many of
the islands current inhabitants fled
Mao's China at the time of the handover
the spectator argued that even the offer
of British citizenship would be a
powerful form of help because it offers
as we put it an insurance policy in case
the worst comes when Beijing takes over
the worst has not come at least not yet
Hong Kong still remains one of the most
prosperous places in the world but with
Xi Jinping now pushing his authoritative
limit but time has come to offer the
fool citizenships that were once denied
and finally to write an historic role
that was Fraser Nelson and now Douglas
Murray it is nearly four years since
black lives matter had their first major
protest in London emulating their US
counterparts the protestors held up
their hands and chanted hands up don't
shoot a chant popularized after the 2014
killing of Michael Brown in Ferguson
Missouri by then it had been known for a
year that before his death Brown almost
certainly said no such thing and had
lunged for the arresting officers gun
before being shot still the London
protests has chanted what they believed
Michael Brown had said as they processed
along Oxford Street accompanied by
unarmed British policemen who couldn't
have shot them if they'd wanted to two
weeks later a crowd gathered in Hyde
Park
chanting hands up don't shoot and other
black lives matter slogans by the end of
the evening a police officer had been
stabbed four other pcs had been injured
and a young man chased into the middle
of one of London's busiest streets and
set upon by three men wielding a machete
it isn't so very far away
this cocktail that is royal in America
but it is one import that we could most
certainly do without seams in London
last weekend were less dramatic than in
America but after the death of George
Floyd at the hands of a Minnesota police
officer now under arrest
they simmered in the same atmosphere
that here is a cause so undeniably clear
and just that anything even the law must
bend before it in the u.s. protests were
swiftly followed by rioting and looting
and burning across the nation the
admirably diverse minority of protesters
who have already ruined this cause are
ransacking and burning an equally
diverse range of targets black homes and
shops among them for their part the
major corporations appear to believe
that the looting of their stores is
simply a good opportunity to reaffirm
their allegiance to black lives matter
announce the hiring of more diversity
officers and otherwise beg the mobs of
protesters and anti-fur activists to
pass them by Justin Timberlake and Harry
Styles were among the celebrities who
committed to pay the legal fees of
people arrested for days
CNN egged things on in similar fashion
then last Friday evening protesters
gathered outside the channel's
headquarters in Atlanta graffiti the
station's logo smashed the glass front
hurled projectiles inside and tried to
storm the building as the police held
them back and terrified journalists
reported live from the lobby of their
own workplace had the attackers been
Trump supporters the network might have
had something to say about it but over
the days that followed frustration and a
sense of not being listened to continued
to be trotted out by CNN as the reasons
why America was burning like America
Britain is still meant to be in Corona
lockdown but here as there
this one caused was granted a Mass
exemption on Sunday thousands of
protesters gathered in Trafalgar Square
and from their possessed to the u.s.
embassy by way of Downing Street where
parts of the crowd stopped to shout [ __ ]
the police and the men and women on duty
politicians who spent recent weeks
shaming people over their lockdown
childcare arrangements seemed supremely
relaxed about this few even dared to
notice one who did attracted the
attention of Doorn Butler MP who just
last month was claiming the Boris
Johnson's promised to relax the lockdown
was sending people out to catch the
virus on Sunday the same dawn Butler her
and a fellow MP who presumed to worry
whether the London protests might lead
to a second corona spike don't you dare
Butler boomed don't even go there our
media turned out to share this black
lives matter exemption clause with
thousands of people gathered around her
a reporter from Sky News declared of
course gatherings of this nature are
illegal at the moment but people are
feeling very strongly about what they
have seen in the United States when the
matter of the law was raised to a
somewhat theatrical young protester he
declared the virus was something we
might not all catch whereas they are
killing people and so he needed to stop
people being killed and beaten up and
blown up in the streets you might say
any number of things to that young man
if you had a chance you might ask why
the police here are so indistinguishable
from the police over there whether the
police over there are quite what he
thinks they are that while the violent
actions of some US police might be
motivated by racism other factors not
least the heavily armed citizenry also
exists
you might even ask why when a white
American like Tony
was suffocated by police in 2016 this
same rioting and looting did not kick
off yet as with his American
counterparts you can predict the lists
of claims that would be trotted out like
other protests as on Sunday he might try
to pretend that Mark Duggan was an
entirely innocent man incomprehensibly
shocked by the racist British police and
besides there is Grenville tower the
hostile environment and much more that
whole panoply of untruths and
half-truths that have been pumped
through our society all but unopposed to
persuade people to believe that the
least racist societies on earth are in
fact the most racist if you are a public
figure it is very tempting to go along
with this like Timberlake and styles but
consequences have a habit of catching up
with people as they do with societies
last Friday the NBA writer Chris Martin
Palmer could be found on social media
posting a photo of a burning building in
Minneapolis burn that [ __ ] down burn it
all down he tweeted a day later he was
denouncing calls for peaceful protests
that doesn't do anything he railed they
don't pay attention until you start
burning [ __ ] a day later
Palmer's own neighborhood was being
attacked they tried to climb the gates
he gasped on social media they had to
beat them back then destroyed a
Starbucks and an hour in front of my
building get these animals the [ __ ] out
of my neighborhood go back to where you
live indeed you have to be careful what
you assert at moments such as this what
claims about your society you are
willing to mainline which lies you are
happy to just wave along that was
Douglas Murray and now Tonya gold now
that I have considered monstermunch I
decide to eat
mindfully I put it in my mouth and it is
if I can taste it for the first time it
is repulsive and I feel cheated this
then is an intervention my husband wrote
in these pages that I'm always watching
spooks eating monster lunch it was a
giggle that went on for 400 words but
his eating monstermunch really so
depraved doesn't J Rainey it skips in
the darkness when he is alone didn't a a
Gilly frazzles I know I do but only when
I'm depressed which is quite often these
days and then I wish I hadn't I could
say I do it for the metaphor I will do
almost anything for metaphor and the
walkers monster munch pickled onion I
won't touch roast beef or flamin hot I
am NOT a monster is such a good one I
wonder if it is deliberate who doesn't
want to consume a monster who doesn't
have one inside them anyway whispering
half lies under their conscious mind the
monster is apparently feet so it is a
bag of feet which doesn't sound so good
I ate the feet of a monster this was
confirmed by walkers in the 1970s in a
small footnote food history I found on
the internet which was confirmed by the
bag or artifact miniature monsters with
big Krispy heads or crunchy claws plucks
straight from pickled onion beasts
nibble the sides will stick your tongue
through the hole and let it melt in all
its oniony vinegary glory the Internet
is fascinating unfiltered voices people
ask questions and Google answers them
the questions are pleading and desolate
they amount through repetition to minors
tragedy a monster munch healthy a
monster munch made from potatoes a
monster munch good for you and as if
asking for tenderness from a narcissist
the answer to everything is no they are
hard to eat I give them that so the
metaphor in my mouth continues it isn't
easy to eat a dragon and it shouldn't be
they will if you have a grab bag a fine
piece of marketing evil for it
insinuates the idea that eating corn
snacks is something jaunty and active
pre-exercise
as if you grab your grab bag and then do
600 press ups and right
to meet the Sun rather than dying in a
puddle of your own fat strip the skin
off the roof of your mouth and leave the
flesh behind it hot and raw as pudding
you can eat your own skin when some of
the corn snacks fall to the floor the
dog sniff smartly interested then walks
away even the dog won't eat them and
he'll eat anything I wonder if I do it
to feel alive
it is a deadening time pandemic fear and
fire and what makes you feel more alive
and maiming yourself and swallowing your
own skin in a socially sanctioned ritual
known as snacking but if it makes you
feel alive it also makes you feel dead
but drugged then a low-grade eurid
easily available late capitalist drug in
the shape of a fictional monster
stinking foot trust me stick with the
opiates if you can take the calm down
Morpheus what you need now you can
follow the tiny lines of your dreams
monster munch on reflection just isn't
the same more late monster munch
information they used to be called the
prime monster so in 1977 when invented
this snack it is absolutely not a crisp
was a political attack on James
Callaghan this makes me wonder if
alongside raising Donald Trump in a
nappy balloon activists would like to
read feet shaped snacks imagined to be
attached in life to their preferred
nemesis it would be pleasingly
meaningless that was Theriault thanks
very much for listening and join us
again next week
[Music]
The Spectator magazine combines incisive
political commentary with books and arts
reviews of unrivaled authority stock up
on your summer reading with a 12 week
subscription in print and online for
just pile pounds plus we'll send you a
copy of Spectator columnist Lionel
Shrivers new book the motion of the body
through space absolutely free go to
Spectator Kudo UK forward slash Lionel